it's almost impossible to think of roles
like James Bond or Han Solo in the hands
of different actors but these are just
two roles that could have been totally
unlike their present form imagine how
differently these classics would be if
casting went the way the filmmakers
originally planned Jurassic Park is such
a well-crafted movie it's hard to
imagine anything changing the effects
hold up surprisingly well decades later
the pacing is tight Jeff Goldblum is
still impossibly sexy it's a great film
however the lead role of dr. Alan Grant
who's played in the movie by Sam Neill
was originally offered to Harrison Ford
for reasons that are obvious if you
think about it grant was a gruff rowdy
scientist paleontologist rather than
archaeologist in his case who could
effectively manage jungle territory
while pursued by a deadly enemy he even
had a cool floppy hat as effectively as
Sam Neill brought the character to life
we all know we'd throw money at a film
about Indiana Jones versus dinosaurs
unfortunately Ford saw it differently he
compared the idea to putting Indiana
Jones on Mars an idea that evidently
made more sense to him a decade and a
half later when they actually had
Indiana Jones meeting space meant you
jumped in a refrigerator to escape an
atomic bomb Ford you couldn't punch a
dinosaur
speaking of Harrison Ford he almost
never had a chance to perform either of
his most closely identified characters
the roles of Indiana Jones and Raiders
of the Lost Ark and Han Solo in the
first Star Wars film were originally
offered to Tom Selleck who turned them
both down this actually made sense at
the time believe it or not the original
draft of Star Wars a new hope imagined
Han Solo as much older than Luke
Skywalker like a kind of black sheep
uncle figure which honestly could have
been confusing with all the other themes
of familial connection in the film by
the time Raiders of the Lost Ark was
being filmed Ford had been in three of
George Lucas's films American Graffiti
and the first two Star Wars movies and
Lucas worried about becoming known for
reusing certain actors he gave Selleck
another shot but it didn't work out as
Selleck was already committed to his
series magnum p.i and the network
wouldn't let him take the film losing
out on Raiders was a particularly bitter
pill for Selleck who ended up cooling
his heel
in Hawaii during an actor strike while
Indiana Jones and company were also on
the island Selleck explained with some
regret I go to Hawaii to start Magnum
the actors go on strike and I had given
my deposit to a landlady and I couldn't
afford a security deposit so I started
working as a handyman in Hawaii
with no job and guess who comes to
Hawaii to finish their movie Raiders of
the Lost Ark so I could have done them
both
Matt Damon has turned down a lot of
major movie roles one of the most
surprising he almost played conflicted
paraplegic former Marine Jake Scully in
James Cameron's sprawling sci-fi action
film avatar the decision was tough on
Damon not only because he was a huge fan
of Cameron's but also because he figured
the star potential of the film could
encourage the actor who took his place
in this case Sam Worthington to
potentially take jobs from him in the
future
unfortunately scheduling conflicts got
in the way leaving us to imagine what
could have been what is he think what
was possibly that's true there's I have
no defense for other than that there was
an actual scheduling conflict while most
of the Kill Bill movies action follows
the ultraviolent exploits and
tribulations of the vengeful bride the
character bill looms large over both
films come on his name's right there in
the title his particular cruelties
obsessions and motivations trickle
through his assassin minions and even
the bride herself all of which is to
explain why when Warren Beatty turned
down the titular role Quentin Tarantino
was forced to do a complete rewrite to
compensate Tarantino explained the
Warren Beatty thing is interesting
because once I cast David Carradine I
did a lot of little rewrites actually
shifting that character into David's
sphere and it was really interesting
reading that first draft because that's
the Warren Beatty version he's more of a
James Bond type character it's honestly
hard to imagine how that film would have
turned out it certainly would have been
a far cry from the gritty suburban
samurai film we wound up seeing once the
james bond producers dumped Pierce
Brosnan a few curious shoulders were
tapped looking to shake things up and
impressed with his sharp dressed killer
performance in American Psycho producer
Barbara broccoli had
meeting with bail to offer him the role
as double-oh-seven however bail a
British actor himself was loathe to take
on a role that embodied what he
considered the worst British stereotypes
all bundled together he was reportedly
cordial in his refusal but at one point
quipped quote I've already played a
serial killer clearly he's not a fan
Nicholas Cage has turned down almost as
many memorable roles as he's taken is
how should we put this nicely
curiously varied career has led him all
over the map even when he wasn't
searching for national treasure among
the many interesting oddities on his
resume he turned down two roles that
went to Keanu Reeves neo in the matrix
and the title character in Constantine
according to cage he turned down the
matrix because he wasn't interested in
flying to Australia to film it while he
was initially more enthusiastic about
Constantine he ended up departing the
project after original director Tarsem
Singh dropped out sparking a pair of
lawsuits between Singh and the studio by
the time the dust settled Reeves was on
board another actor considered for the
role of neo in the matrix was Will Smith
and although it ended up launching a
blockbuster trilogy Smith seems really
at peace with turning down a massive
once-in-a-lifetime role speaking to
Wired he admitted that a project like
The Matrix is really difficult to sell
in a pitch and that when the movie was
first described to him quote he didn't
see it after watching the film later
Smith also felt Reeves was a better fit
saying I would have absolutely messed up
the matrix at that point I wasn't smart
enough of an actor to let the movie be
where as Keanu was smart enough to let
it be just let the movie and the
director tell the story and don't try to
perform every moment however he doesn't
quite have that level of zen-like peace
about wild wild west the film he
accepted instead of the matrix although
the movie was a financial success
critics tore it to pieces and in
hindsight he admits his performance was
a cash grab and led him to vow never to
take on a project again just for the
money he presumably made his vow while
reclining on a pile of cash
[Music]
[Applause]
Al Pacino is possibly one of the
greatest actors that ever lived with a
career bringing to life some of the most
memorable characters in modern cinema
which makes it even more incredible to
consider what might have been for any
number of roles naturally every director
wanted a piece of Pacino at his peak
unfortunately he couldn't be everywhere
at once at various times he had the
potential to be Han Solo in Star Wars
Willard in Apocalypse Now Axel Foley
from Beverly Hills Cop John McClane from
die hard and even freaking Rambo instead
of being on a couple posters in your
college dorm room he could potentially
have been on all of them through the 90s
and into the early 2000s the name Bruce
Willis was synonymous with action hero
that's almost entirely due to his role
as John McClane a wisecracking regular
cop thrust into extraordinary
life-or-death situations in a string of
die hard films when the original die
hard hit theaters in 1988 Willis was
seen as an unconventional if not risky
choice to headline a full throttle
action movie at the time Willis was
known almost entirely for his
emmy-nominated role as cheeky private
detective David Addison on the TV
rom-com moonlighting
according to screenwriter Steven D'Souza
in die hard in oral history filmmakers
hired Willis quote in desperation every
big action hero and tough-guy actor of
the 80s passed on die hard including
Arnold Schwarzenegger Sylvester Stallone
James Caan Burt Reynolds and Richard
Gere Deadpool marked a major comeback
from Ryan Reynolds who's once promising
career had been knocked off course by a
few bombs chief among them the 2010 DC
Comics movie Green Lantern the superhero
adventure was both a critical and
commercial failure earning back about
half its 200 million dollar budget at
the American box office
Reynolds explained to Variety after
Green Lantern I was pretty much
unhireable but while his star was
falling another guy's was rising jon
hamm the annually Emmy nominated star of
the AMC 1960s period piece Mad Men seems
to have dodged a big green bullet as DC
aggressively pursued him to be a big
screen superhero Hamm told GQ they came
after me pretty hard for Green Lantern
but I was like yeah that's not what I
want to do in the 1990s Leonardo
DiCaprio was the Boy Wonder of Hollywood
finding fame fortune and teen idol
status with roles like troubled teen
Luke on growing pains Jack Dawson in
Titanic and Romeo in Baz Luhrmann's
Romeo and Juliet it only makes sense
that the fresh-faced box-office draw
would be given the chance to play actual
Boy Wonder Robin
aka Dick Grayson and Warner Brothers
ongoing Batman franchise in 2015 he told
shortlist that he was under
consideration for the part which would
have started with 1995's Batman Forever
saying I never screen-tested I had a
meeting with Joel Schumacher it was just
one meeting and no I didn't end up doing
it as I recall I took the meeting but
didn't want to play the role DiCaprio
mentioned two other parts in big movies
that he met with filmmakers about before
taking himself out of contention Anakin
Skywalker in the Star Wars prequels and
spider-man in spider-man in 1996 and
1997 Will Smith starred in the
back-to-back summer blockbusters
Independence Day and men in black the
movies marked his official transition
from sitcom star to Hollywood a-lister
with The Fresh Prince of bel-air having
ended its run just weeks before
Independence Day hit theaters I make
this look good
Smith wasn't the first choice to play
rookie agent J and men in black however
another actor known primarily for one
huge TV role was offered at first David
Schwimmer
known to millions as lovelorn
paleontologist Ross on friends while he
was shooting the comedy the pallbearer
for Miramax the studio was so confident
the future box-office bomb would be a
hit that it wanted to sign Schwimmer to
a three movie deal
Schwimmer agreed to it if they let him
also direct since you've been gone and
cast everyone from his Chicago Theatre
Company the film went into production
and Schwimmer gave all of his friends
roles he explained on the awards chatter
podcast about a month before production
I get the call about men in black which
was a direct conflict with directing
that film I just said I can't these are
my closest friends in the world this is
their first shot at a movie my first
shot at directing nor could heat the lay
filming the movie in favor of men in
black because he'd be do
if friends MIB producers had to move on
and they picked Smith check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stars are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]